[Musique]
le bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le mardi 19 avril
voici les titres onze associations
dédiées à l'accompagnement des personnes
en situation de handicap mental unis
elles ont créé en février le collectif
andy social 78 l'objectif mieux faire
entendre la voix des professionnels du
social et médico-social nous en parlons
avec deux présidents d'associations
membres du collectif gîm en 5 avant le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle des électeurs devront
trancher entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen à quelques jours du scrutin
quelles sont les attentes des
enseignants une institutrice de maurepas
témoigne et puis même en ce week-end
prolongé de pâques les sportifs étaient
sur les terrains ce week-end retour sur
les principaux résultats et notamment en
football on connaît désormais l'affiché
de la finale de la coupe des yvelines
seniors mais avant de développer ses
titres cette information révélée par nos
confrères du parisien dans leur édition
du jour ce samedi à bouafles 68 animaux
ont été sauvés par les autorités 60
poule 7 cochon et une autruche les
gendarmes ont été alertés par un
promeneur sur place les animaux vivaient
dans des conditions déplorables sans eau
ni nourriture plusieurs cadavres de
poules renard et blair ont été également
découverts et les animaux ont pu être
mises en sécurité dans une pension à
chevaux à houdan et un énorme élan de
solidarité a permis de recueillir et des
légumes et fruits pour les nourrir la
majorité des rescapés sont désormais et
dans de nouvelles familles d'accueil
dont les yvelines et en essonne
l'autruche devrait-elle être accueillis
dans un zoo refuge une enquête a été
ouverte pour permettre d'identifier le
propriétaire des lieux
[Musique]
andy social 78 tire la sonnette d'alarmé
le secteur du social et médico social
est en danger en février ce collectif a
été créé dans les yvelines par onze
associations
l'objectif c'est de demander la
reconnaissance pour tous les
professionnels du secteur afin d'assurer
la continuité de l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de handicap
mental point par les deux invités en
plateau josé lucas bonsoir son président
de l'association us pour insertion
éducation soins qui fait partie de ce
collectif l'association elle est basée à
trappes également jean michel rey terre
qui était avec nos bonsoir vous êtes
vous le président d'une autre
association président d'avenir apei dans
dont le siège social se situe lui du
côté de carrières sous poissy alors si
on revient aux origines de ce collectif
g10 fondé en février pourquoi pourquoi
l'avoir créé on imagine le contexte post
crise sanitaire qui à anaky avoir
endommagé la situation qui était déjà
compliquée quel est le contexte
aujourd'hui klose et luca le contexte de
création il est il est tout simple il
s'est avéré qu'en fin d'année dernière
on a eu un temps où on a senti un gros
problème un gros problème de
rémunération un problème de valorisation
des métiers du médico social
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
dans le public toute la partie privée
sur toutes les associations rien ne
s'était passé donc il a fallu qu'on
réagisse on s'est tous mis on se parle
régulièrement et là on s'est dit il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose il faut
faire passer ce message pouvoir
sensibiliser un peu notamment sur 78 nos
élus et c'est à ce titre qu'on a créé ce
collectif on a réuni 11 grosse
association au fait du secteur et puis
on s'est réuni aujourd'hui pour la
première fois c'était vraiment la grande
journée inaugurale trees on se voit en
permanence mais là on s'est vus vraiment
en présentiel grâce à saint quentin en
yvelines qui nous a prêté une salle donc
c'est vrai que c'était absolument
superbe allah comme l'employé à
elancourt et c'est vrai que c'était
vraiment une très belle initiative et on
a pu faire une journée on a pu débattre
pour ne les actions qu'on pourrait mener
est ce qu'on a à dire aujourd'hui en
matière de valorisation de ces métiers
du médico social des actions à mener des
messages à faire passer jean michel reyt
en avoir parlé dans un instant est
aujourd'hui une nouvelle étape faisait
lucas le rappelait c'est cette première
réunion en présentiel là c'est le vrai
lancement on va dire effectif
on va dire de ce collectif aujourd'hui
oui enfin on s'était déjà réuni dauphin
auparavant quelques communiqués de
presse avaient déjà été sortis on avait
un travail en amont qu'avez qu'avec
avait été fait mais l'idée c'était face
et surtout que ce comité il était il est
surtout été consolidée à la suite des
oubliés du ségur et donc est donc là
aujourd'hui on commence à avancer virée
dans les dents les dispositions du
gouvernement va prendre et c'est aussi
des voir les objectifs que l'on aurait
dans le temps faim dans les années avant
les moyens dans les mois à venir et la
manière dont on se réunirait entre entre
présidents et directeurs généraux
vous parlez du ségur de la santé a
annoncé par le gouvernement en plein
contexte de crise sanitaire avec l'un
des objectifs c'est aussi de valoriser
les soignants notamment d'augmenter leur
rémunération avec plusieurs ajustements
en février c'est le dernier le
gouvernement a annoncé l'élargissement
du ségur aux éducateurs spécialisés avec
une hausse de 183 euros par mois le
compte n'y est pas il ya encore des
métiers qui ne sont pas concernés par
ces guerriers encore des oubliés
aujourd'hui de se saisir de la santé
vivait dans la notamment toute la partie
administrative
les chauffeurs par exemple n'ont donc
nous tous ces gens là qui tourne autour
du médico-social et qui sont vraiment
vitaux dans le cadre de l'accueil de
l'accompagnement des handicapés c'est
vrai que c'est une part aujourd'hui
cette part elle doit se résumer à
peut-être 10% on s'est vraiment je peux
dire un film mais c'est important pour
nous parce que ces gens là travaillent
et sans accompagnement cents cuisiniers
sans son chauffeur et ben y'a pas un
accompagnement de qualité et ça c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qu'on veut
qu'on veut repousser et qu'on veut
continuer à on veut parler et on veut
véritablement que des choses pas faite
là-dessus confiance sont des métiers
essentiels ou aujourd'hui
abbas et des métiers essentiels ce qu'il
faut dire aussi c'est qu'on n'a pas les
financements aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que la problématique aussi c'est que des
financements été annoncée dès l'année
dernière qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
encore arrivés là c'est notre métier
c'est vrai que l'on peut dire que 80 90
% de la population au niveau des du
personnel normalement rentrer dans le
cadre du ségur aujourd'hui le problème
c'est qu'on n'a pas encore les finances
même ces financements devraient être
signés il manque un décret donc ça
devrait ça a été annoncé on devrait les
avoir anges 1 avec un effet rétroactif
mais pour l'instant rien avec mais on
n'a pas de certitudes là dessus c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai problème une
problématique aussi aujourd'hui c'est
que beaucoup de postes ne sont pas
pourvus dans le secteur du social et mes
livres je tire enfin dans les yvelines
enfin nous en tant qu'association c'est
qu'il ya 400 pages 400 preuve qu'ils
sont pas pourvus au moins au moins 400
postes et ça nuit à l'accompagnement des
établissements des personnes que l'on
accompagne comment elle explique c'est
la rémunération qui est moindre c'est
aussi les difficultés de ce métier aussi
dans ce contexte post crise sanitaire je
crois que moi le balbutiement qui a eu
enfin avec le gouvernement qui n'a pas à
bord qui n'a pas apporté enfin qui n'a
pas je dirais donc
enfin le culte fin qu'il n'a pas et
apporter l'équivalent du ségur dans nos
associations ne donne pas envie aux
personnes différentes personnes de venir
travailler chez nous donc et une revers
une revalorisation un petit peu des
métiers c'était également un travail que
l'on aura à faire dans le temps il faut
valoriser nos métiers juste pour
préciser un pour ce collectif qui
représente je le rappelle aux
associations pour montrer aussi tout la
conséquence bondé dans les yvelines un
dix mille personnes vulnérables sont
accompagnés par ces associations scarred
ce qui représente aussi 3500
professionnels ont parlé des
conséquences directes conséquences sur
l'accompagnement qui peut être moindre
les conséquences directes ça pourrait
être la fermeture d'établissement alors
qu'il n'avait pas le personnel pour
pouvoir accueillir les handicapés c'est
qu'on peut en arriver à ce point là le
bon on n'en est pas là et c'est vrai
qu'on arrive à le gérer mais par un
effort encore accrue qui est fait par
tous nos professionnels avec des équipes
réduites et c'est vrai que le fait
d'avoir ces problèmes de recrutement
pénalise l'accompagnement donc
aujourd'hui on arrive à ça à assurer un
accompagnement digne pour l'ensemble de
nos adultes où l'enfant handicapé mais
on est à la limite on est véritablement
à la limite et c'est vrai que c'est très
très dur pour que nos téléspectateurs se
rendre compte qu est-ce que c'est
assurer un accompagnement au quotidien
de ces personnes en situation d'handicap
mental c'est très très complexe assurer
un accompagnement s'est assuré la partie
accompagnement pu en serre l'accueil
déjà rien que l'accueil le matin quand
vous allez le chercher on va chercher
des handicapés pour une grosse partie on
va les chercher au domicile déjà il ya
cette première partie le chauffeur un
film n'est pas de chauffeur vous n'allez
pas le chercher donc en fait vous
demander aux familles de vous l'amenez
ou alors ce qu'ils sont c'est toujours
un vrai sujet donc ça c'est déjà la base
ensuite vous avez tout l'accompagnement
médico-social c'est le soin c'est là
toute la dalle est tous tout ce qui est
touche à l'inclusion essayé de lui
apporter les éléments qui lui permettent
de rentrer dans la société tout ça c'est
vraiment un ensemble et tous nos
professions travail pour arriver à faire
sauter cet amalgame et avoir quelque
chose de concret et qu'ils soient
efficaces pour nos pour nous handicaper
en fait l'une des rares questions oui
allez on avait public qui vont de
l'enfance jusqu'à des personnes qui sont
très âgés concerne âgées donc
l'accompagnement il est vraiment très
diversifié et par exemple c'est vrai que
par exemple les infirmières bain par le
biais des établissements dans d'autres
départements qui manquent et
d'infirmières et qui a voté pratiquement
obligé de fermer pendant plusieurs jours
parce que il n'y avait pas
d'accompagnement et qui prenaient des
risques parce que quand on est dans des
foyers d'accueil médicalisés si on a pas
d'accompagnement d'accompagnement
d'infirmières et bien on met en danger
les personnes qu'on accompagne on peut
mettre en danger les personnes qu'on
accompagne une dernière question est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que cette
thématique a été abordé dans ce contexte
on est dans l'entre-deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle demain il ya
le débat de l'entre-deux tours est-ce
que ça a été un thème oublié à votre
avis très peu on peut dire que le
handicap a été un petit peu oubliée donc
alors il faut on va on va défendre un
petit peu là les publics c'est vrai que
des mesures ont été prises juste avant
donc on en attend maintenant d'en voir
vraiment les conséquences sur le terrain
mais c'est vrai que ces mesures elles
ont été prises donc globalement il ya
quand même du positif mais on peut il
faut faut avouer que quand on écoute les
débats on parle très peu le handicap sap
a été un sujet un sujet d'actualité
c'est en tout cas ce collectif andy
sociale 70,9 à parler de ces sujets on
peut avoir plus d'informations sur le
collectif 1 via le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
d'avoir été avec nous josé luca et jean
michel rey terre je rappelle josé lucas
président des us et jean michel ritter
président d'avenir apei 78 donc deux
associations qui font partie de ce
collectif andy social 78 qui a été créé
en février dans les yvelines et et qui
est basée à carrières-sur-seine j'ai dit
à carrières sous poissy les pardons
carrière sur scène voilà pour la
précision et à huer ses bases et
attrapes merci d'avoir été avec nous
dans l'actualité également cette
mobilisation ce matin à achères une
trentaine d'enseignants du lycée louise
weiss était en grève protestation contre
le manque de moyens horaires pour
l'établissement une baisse de 74 eur
annuels prévus pour la dotation horaire
globale de la rentrée prochaine elle
s'explique par la fermeture de deux
classes les enseignants craignent une
dégradation de l'homme scolaire sur
place et de l'accompagnement des élèves
c'est justement une enseignante que nous
avons tendu notre micro à cinq jours du
deuxième tour de la présidentielle
quelles sont les attentes pour le futur
président envers le futur président ou
futur président de la république elle a
été interrogée par mathilde au front je
m'appelle les divines grosjean je suis
enseignante depuis 13 ans maintenant en
maternelle depuis trois ans au quotidien
c'est la classe la classe maternelle
donc
donc c'est des ateliers c'est de la
phonologie des chants des histoires à
lire de la motricité donc du sport
s'est également beaucoup de civisme donc
la maternelle c'est un lieu de
socialisation donc on apprend aux
enfants à vivre ensemble à grandir
ensemble à travailler ensemble on en
fait des petits citoyens
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui peut être un peu
surprenant de la part d'un enseignant
mais j'attends pas forcément d'être
payés plus j'aime mon métier j'ai pas
besoin d'être payés plus en revanche je
pense qu'il faut vraiment dégager
beaucoup d'argent pour payer davantage
les gens qui travaillent avec nous donc
payer davantage les jeunes qui démarrent
qui ont besoin d'un attrait pour entrer
dans le métier et pour y rester parce
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
professeurs stagiaires qui au bout d'un
an s'en vont et pour également recruter
des remplaçants parce qu on est très
content de faire notre métier mais quand
on a quarante enfants dans notre classe
à gérer on peut pas bien s'en occuper et
on peut pas faire notre métier
correctement même si on est motivé même
si on aime ça même si on veut bien
travailler plus longtemps peut-être
faire des grosses journées mais on peut
pas faire des grosses journées dans ces
conditions là donc il faut repenser la
distribution de l'argent au sein de
l'éducation nationale
deuxième tour du scrutin tv 78 vous en
apprend plus sur le rôle de président de
la république c'est avec raphaël mata
duvignau professeur de droit public à
l'université versailles saint quentin un
membre du collectif des surligneurs ce
soir focus sur les pratiques du pouvoir
présidentiel une constitution c'est un
esprit et les institutions une pratique
justement qu'en est il de la pratique du
pouvoir présidentiel la constitution
d'une à 158 instaurer un régime marqué
par un point négatif fort l'institution
présence hier devant en effet être
immunisé contre les vicissitudes d'un
parlementarisme dominateur par la
révision constitue de 1962 le président
élu au suffrage universel
asus s'émanciper dire a ajouté le
parlementaire et accentuer sa suprématie
au sein du système institutionnel et
depuis l'instauration du quinquennat il
voit sa présence renforcée puisque la
corrélation entre la durée des mandats
présentiel et les députés fait du
premier le véritable chef de la majorité
ainsi le président bénéficie d'une
légitimité constitutionnelle et
populaire qui fait de lui le véritable
dépositaire de la souveraineté nationale
toutefois la nature politique du régime
faris sensiblement au gré des
circonstances politiques et l'étendue du
pouvoir du président république
dépendent de la coïncidence ou non du
des majorités présidentielles et
parlementaires
dans le premier cas et choisit librement
les prix ministres qui lui sont
subordonnés il a même la latitude de
l'huile demandé sa démission
le régime présente alors un caractère
est présent cialiste et dans les faits
c'est bien le président qui détermine et
conduit la politique de la nation et
assure enfin les différences arbitrage
en cohabitation toutefois le président
doit choisir le premier ministre parmi
les membres de la majorité parlementaire
pour que le gouvernement bénéficie du
soutien et de la confiance de
l'assemblée s'agissant des ministres la
pratique a montré que le président
dispose au tout au plus d'un droit de
veto pour certaines fonctions dit de
souveraineté mais en réalité
l'influencent de chef de l'état est très
réduite et la france devient un régime
primo ministériel dit à l'européenne la
salle est vrai mais qui est donc un
régime marqué par une imprévisibilité
une insécurité quant à la répartition
des compétences au sein même de
l'exécutif alors au final le président a
besoin d'une majorité pour gouverner et
les élections législatives à venir son
enfant davantage puisque c'est elle qui
vont attribuer réellement le pouvoir et
en vue du deuxième tour 49 mer des
yvelines appelle à voter pour emmanuel
macron ce mardi ses élus de sensibilité
à diverses ont signé une tribune commune
publiée dans le journal du parisien
initiative du maire de poissy karl olive
rejoints par les édiles de versailles
saint-germain-en-laye les mureaux ou
encore mantes la jolie concernant marine
le pen les signataires expriment de
vives craintes sur la liberté de la
presse le pluralisme politique ou encore
l'europe elle représente pour eux je
cite l'extrême droite qui ne dit pas son
nom
[Musique]
michael mino roma rejoint en plateau
bonsoir pour parler d'un tout autre
sujet vous êtes le journaliste sport de
la rédaction de tv 78 et même en ce
week-end de pont michael de nombreuses
rencontres étaient programmées dans les
yvelines à commencer par du football et
les demi finales de la coupe des
yvelines ce match était particulièrement
attendu par les amoureux du football
dans les yvelines le voisin fc leader de
d1 le district rosso fait plaisir à
leader de 2e division de district sur sa
pelouse une rencontre entre deux équipes
en forme après 45 minutes équilibrées la
rencontre s'est décanté en seconde
période avec tout d'abord ce but de
voisins sur cette tête après à ce beau
centre mais plaisir ne renonce pas les
plaisirs roi arrive à recoller au score
avec ce but mais à voisins on voit le
premier que ça le problème
très joli trait au deuxième poteau mais
plaisir ne renonce pas les plaisirs roi
arrive à recoller au score avec ce but
mes voisins remportera finalement la
victoire grâce à ce coup de canon en fin
de match un vrai plaisir que l'on voit
le but d'un plaisir quelques instants
voilà le coup de canon c'est du plaisir
pour les yeux azur est instantané le
gardien n'a quasiment aucune chance
d'arrêter la frappe de 1 ce sera le
score final
on écoute les réactions micro de céline
chien je pense qu'on a la gestion des
émotions je pense que quand on était sur
des temps faibles on a bien géré ça on a
été costaud mais un duel et puis on
s'invite l'autre à l'arrivée on sait
qu'on marque tout le temps donc on
savait que ça allait arriver vers le
score une fois qu'on avait ouvert le
score on savait que voilà même si on
n'était pas capable de gagner le match
on alla voir une occasion que justement
pour les punir son enfant et ça a payé
une grosse déception puisque je pense
qu'on a quand même fait largement jeu
égal avec cette équipe qui est en tête
de la première division
on a eu les situations pour
pour faire basculer le match sur notre
faveur malheureusement on n'a pas réussi
à concrétiser et puis après sur sur une
petite erreur à la fin on concède ce
deuxième but qui nous fait très mal
c'est donc une grande première pour le
club de voisins-le-bretonneux forcément
voisins ne veut pas s'arrêter là on
écoute le milieu de terrain buteur
une hyper content franchement on va
essayer cycling club parce que voilà
parce que nos bonnes saisons championnat
l'ont fait une finale en coupe qu'on
essaie de faire un doublé c'est pas fini
encore il reste encore quelques matches
mais on peut le faire mais qui voisin
va-t-il affronter en finale demain ce
sera à brûler le club voilà tout le
monde se pose la question et bien ce
sera le club de trappes l'équipe 2 s'est
imposé 2 buts à 1 sur sa pelouse les
trappistes affronteront donc les vie
sinon à la finale est programmée le 19
juin prochain ce sera à montigny le
bretonneux grégory gervis saint
quentinois en terre saint-quentinoise
pour cette finale de coupe davis et ça
moi je vais réserver métier parce que ça
sera une belle finale à mon avis on
jouait d'autres demi-finale de la coupe
des yvelines cette fois-ci cdm ça veut
dire championnat du dimanche matin et
des actes se réveiller très tôt pour
jouer à 9h30 le matin très tôt un nous
on est plus sur les matchs de
l'après-midi en général pour télé 78
mais quand même on s'intéresse à ce
championnat du dimanche matin après de
bons résultats en championnat et une
troisième place villiers le mahieu se
qualifie pour la finale de la coupe des
yvelines cdm le club à dominer les
portugais de plaisir à domicile devant
plusieurs dizaines de supporters score
final 2 partout et 4 tirs au but à 3
football toujours la 4e division
française c'est-à-dire la nationale 2
des yvelinois qui cartonne toujours et
un premier but plein de symboles
exactement à grégory alors le seul ce
premier but on va
juste dans un instant un championnat
avec du suspense à tous les étages pour
le club yvelinois pour la montée vers ça
et reprend sa marche en avant après deux
matches nuls les versaillais l'ont
emporté 3 0 à domicile contre vitré avec
trois buts signés christopher iba il
avance anton victoire qui leur permet de
conserver la première place du
classement et de se rapprocher de la
montée is on a quatre points d'avancé
sur la réserve de lorient et sept sur
chartres de son côté poissy s'est imposé
3 0 sur le terrain de la réserve de caen
et on va voir le ce dernier but le
dernier but il élève de romane yallo
venco l'attaquant ukrainien de 27 ans
entraînée depuis un mois et demi avec
les pisciacais suite au conflit en
ukraine joueur qui évolue en deuxième
division avant la guerre dans son pays a
pu s'engager avec les jaune et bleu
semaine dernière il a donc réussi sa
grande première avec ce but et il a pesé
sur le jeu de l'équipe si un but tout
plein de symboles et je reprécise juste
les résultats parce qu'ils ne se sont
pas affichés à l'écran ce n'était pas la
bonne animation qu'on avait un 2e
victoire 3 buts à 0 pour nos club
yvelinois à versailles un qui l'a
emporté avec un triplé de christopher et
bailly et voici également 3 buts à 0
face à la réserve de caen on parle de
football encore mais football américain
cette fois ci jamais haquin d'un
championnat de deuxième division les
templiers d'elancourt ans de plus en
plus de mal à performer les élans
courtois se sont une nouvelle fois
inclinés ils ont perdu 25 à 0 sur le
terrain des dragons de paris à
l'occasion de la 8e journée au
classement et l'encours est toujours
deuxième de sa poule et peut toujours
espérer monter en fin de saison du
handball à présent rien ne va plus pour
les féminines de montigny le bretonneux
les josine montay l'on enregistré une
nouvelle défaite ce dimanche 17 avril
elles se sont inclinés 29 à 28 face à
l'eic césaire levillain l'occasion de la
20e journée une défaite qui fait mal au
classement vont-ils aux bretons ne reste
à la huitième place sur 12 équipes
engagées dans la poule on termine ce
tour d'horizon par du rugby dans
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir a
concédé la défaite sur le teint de
sarcelles à l'occasion de la 22e journée
du championnat la logique a été
respectée face aux troisièmes le score
27 à 20 plaisir est toujours septième à
trois journées de la fin du championnat
il reste trois matches pour espérer
jouer les phases finales merci michael
pour toutes ces précisions et ce
week-end c'est un tout autre sport que
vous vous êtes à donner c'est la chasse
aux oeufs à l'occasion de pâques la
ferme de gally à saint cyr l'école
organisait sa grande chasse aux
chocolats tout le week-end et les
gourmands ont fait le déplacement en
garde votre reportage michael avec la
voix de céline chardin
l'objectif est clair ce samedi 16 avril
à la ferme de gally de saint-cyr-l'ecole
trouver du chocolat pour cela ces jeunes
explorateurs sillonnent les champs du
site pour amasser des fosses de colorer
leur collecte est ensuite échangé avec
de vrais gourmandise on a une petite
règle du jeu on attend duff jaune à
trouver blanc bleu etc on donne une
petite boîte
of aux enfants ils remplissent leurs
petits oeufs et sinon la nouveauté de
cette année c'est qu'on a caché 5,9 de
or dans la ferme mais moi je suis pas au
courant ou ses cachets et ceux qui
trouvent ils auront une petite surprise
au moment de notre tournage un seul f
d'or avait été trouvé mais les enfants
ont tous garni leur boîte au total près
de 6000 paniers ont été distribués sur
deux jours à l'occasion de cette fête d
eux on retrouve à chaque fois doux
chocolat est parfois plus à l'intérieur
est ce que tu en penses quoi de cette
journée parce qu'elle a des yeux pas il
fait beau on est bien la ferme de gally
fidèle à elle même et on fait plaisir à
notre enfant aujourd'hui c'est super
c'est vraiment sympa pour les enfants
cette chasse aux oeufs colorés en
parallèle de cette chasse les visiteurs
pouvaient participer à différents
ateliers créatifs autour de la ferme des
oeufs de la laine ou encore de la nature
pour respirent tous ensemble dehors
qu'on apprenne qu'on joue qu'on soit
ensemble on partage voilà des moments
simples partagent ensemble et que tous
les sens sont en éveil à travers nos
animaux les couleurs des prêts qu'ils
changent et les yeux de couleur etc une
journée pour se construire de beaux
souvenirs en famille rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition de
la fête des oeufs à la ferme de gally un
rendez vous avant de refermer cette
édition samedi prochain la clinique des
franciscaines à versailles organise des
portes ouvertes une journée dédiée
également recrutement de nombreux postes
en cdd et cdi sont à pourvoir pour les
infirmiers sages femmes est les
candidats pourront profiter d'une visite
guidée de 9h à 12h déposer leur cv
effectué un premier entretien avec les
ressources humaines vous pouvez d'ores
et déjà envoyer votre cv et vous
inscrire par mail à l'adresse qui
s'affiche dans cette animation
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant le 7-8
culture présentée par céline agathe son
go une émission en partie tourné au
palais du roi de rome c'est à
rambouillet quelle belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]